it's Wednesday the 1st of July if you
ain't got the rent money you might as
well get a 10 kilos and the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by on it listen when it comes to
supplements you know you guys know I
don't [ __ ] around okay we've been on for
seven years for seven years we had them
as a matter of fact welcome to episode
800 on July 1st 2020 in the middle of a
[ __ ] pandemic we're still here
pushing ahead you understand me
you [ __ ] ready to rock it's the
first of July it's a whole new [ __ ]
month
take this [ __ ] melee
[Music]
it's your life first you've been locked
in the house for how long let I want to
put your back unbelievable they let you
out for a week then they call you up
with we forgot something and now they
want to put us back but no big [ __ ]
deal just another day in the life guys
that's it I'm saying this is it
it's Corona Ville get it through your
[ __ ] head the next couple days you're
gonna hear about some [ __ ] that went
down whatever don't be surprised it's
[ __ ] Corona little guys you cannot be
around larger [ __ ] crowds you could
do once twice three times eventually
it's gonna grab you it's gotten a couple
comics now you'll be hearing about
developments the next couple days when
it goes after these guys they were
trying to entertain you buh-buh-buh-buh
a bar I've said it since day one guys
listen it's at an all-time peak right
now think about yourself think about the
people that you bring it back to you
know I don't give a [ __ ] how you live
your life you want to stop called us you
ever do what you need to do do with a
[ __ ] mask on I don't care if you put
a [ __ ] a little hole in the straw put
the straw in your [ __ ] nose just be
careful out there right guys this thing
ain't over yet
what it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
to be alive what am i smoking debt from
[ __ ] urban trees you know how they
take Cammie over there which is the name
of the of the restraint listen whatever
I'm smoking is death okay 31 they're
getting strong really strong it's like
those flies of my basement right they're
getting stronger and stronger I mean I
gave one I gave him something different
here today
I gave one of them I experimented I gave
one of them some of my toe shavings like
from the [ __ ] bong Kong guy toe he's
[ __ ] on fire lately isn't [ __ ]
dying to get out of there he's like
[ __ ] hoodies wouldn't escape from out
the trash you got to see him break out
from within the glass [ __ ] don't worry
about nothing well I talk to people but
it's something I've overlooked for a
long time and listen to these [ __ ]
sirens people getting stabbed by the
minute
when you give a [ __ ] about Jimmy Kimmel
[ __ ] putting on blackface funding
look at that the [ __ ] ambulance is
going the cops are going they got these
poor cops on bikes they're about to get
shot me [ __ ] this is like Target [ __ ]
practice your and they copy on a bike
quit it's over you a ride no bike no
more what are you [ __ ] Sheryl Crow's
boyfriend what's his name
yeah whole sudden your Lance Armstrong
he didn't become a Coptic beef Lance
Armstrong if you're a cop and you ain't
in the tank he is slipping right now you
understand me and you better have three
other cops in [ __ ] it so you could shoot
it out with these [ __ ] because
it's rough on the streets out there but
anyway what I want to talk to you people
that is a beautiful situation that's
going on but I've overlooked I've
overlooked it till about three [ __ ]
weeks ago and I gotta tell you man
it's one of the best moves that you know
has ever [ __ ] happened to me I mean
I've taken guys a little story just
let's start off with 1999 it was a
holiday night I'm gonna turn I'm gonna
tell you one night it was I just want
you to paint your [ __ ] minds with
this one you know I started comedy in 91
I got separated for months later I found
the new girlfriend in January I dated
her till about September and she moved
to New York you know we stayed in touch
on the phone but things happened I ended
up back in New York in 93 we hooked up a
couple times but it wasn't the same she
had a day job I was trying to drive a
limo you know it was just [ __ ] and
I'm doing my cocaine the whole [ __ ]
deal like go to New York I stayed with
George you called until the podcast I
lived with him I think I was with him
nine months in that apartment I never
brought a girl over whenever I hooked up
with that girl we hooked up in a [ __ ]
living room she had a it was a good
little studio apartment so she had a
roommate in the studio apartment Oh now
so we I sleep in the kitchen we had open
the bathroom and my shower feet were
going the [ __ ] bathroom
kitchen was so small and then at the end
of the night after you [ __ ] did your
thing a mouse would run by tremendous I
would have to [ __ ] leave there once I
saw the mouse but that's not the story
after I went to Colorado and I lived in
a nomad life as far as relationships
were concerned I was alone I was alone
and that's how I wanted to be and got
married I had been through a divorce I
wanted to be alone that's what happens I
said you know what I gave it a try I'm a
Catholic there ain't no coming back to
this so what this means is I'm gonna
leave look the single man's life when I
started doing comedy in 95 when I went
on the road you know you're living the
single life I met a girl we went to
Seattle blah blah blah we moved down
here things weren't working out first
she went her way I was on my way
amicably we hooked up six months later
not sexually as friends I stay with her
for a few months and it was just really
weird like I wasn't lonely at all I was
single and the the dumb [ __ ] was nice
from time to time but you stole along
now it was when I came here with her I
was duking it out with these people with
her and then once we broke up I was
pretty much alone I was pretty much
alone for like three [ __ ] years in
those three years was just craziness
like you know we were talking about the
store and stuff like that but one
particular incident that happened one
night was I was at a comedy club one
night and I met this girl in between
shows and then when I got off the second
show the headline that would come on
behind me and she was in the show room
with her girlfriends and they came to
the bar and me her the owner we all
started talking about my BA one thing
it's a big cocaine Club this club is a
very big cocaine comedy club so it was
my type of club we did a couple [ __ ]
blast everybody was happy was the old it
would keep it open
he knew what time it was and one thing
led to the other mean the chick
disappeared
we ended up in the owners office and we
ended up getting naked in the [ __ ] in
all this office one thing leads to
another we finished we walked out like
nothing happened our girlfriends don't
know nothing nobody knows nothing we go
back to the bars is nothing I start
talking to other people would talk to
them between but we both it's a big
night and we both get caught up and
what's going on and often I'm doing my
thing and guess what happens what I turn
around and she's gone and she's making
out with another comic oh no and I'm
like what the [ __ ] just happened so I
didn't say nothing I went home and I was
like you know it's not like I lost my
girl or another comic we already did
what we needed to do at the club on a
play on his desk
the owner calls me the next day bah bah
right there that [ __ ] with me a little
bit but that's how you go that's what my
life is up to like I signed up to be a
comic but this other lifestyle that
comes with it is enjoyable I'm not gonna
lie to you but it is it is this what
this is gonna be from 65 you know when I
was a kid I was watch those Charles
Bronson movies and you know yes as Jill
well Ireland played in the movies his
wife but Charles Bronson was always a
single guy whether it's hard times
whether a Deathwish his wife was in the
hospital she's got all the [ __ ] that
they [ __ ] her up and then you know
several movies he was saying are I can't
come to mechanic he was single the one
he did where he was the bout there the
Mountie he was single he was always
single so as a kid I always envisioned
myself getting older and being single
was no big [ __ ] deal like that that's
just the way life is
either you're cut out for romance or
you're not cut out for romance but that
99 really [ __ ] with me a little bit I
was 36 years old you know about that -
turn turn 37 I wasn't thinking of a
family but I
you said something to me once I asked
you what happen to that person and you
said to me that they wanted they wanted
a life of having a trailer and having
dogs and living like the nomads life and
that wasn't for you you know I'm saying
like even though I was a comic and I was
having these bushwa [ __ ]
relationships it got old
it really did get old you know and I did
some drugs and the whole thing and I got
a hold and it's not like I yearned for a
girlfriend because I know I was in the
Mafia I'm in the Mafia I'm in comedy I'm
in probably nine years I'm trying to get
[ __ ] recognized I got no time to be
going on dinners I got no time I got no
money I got none of that [ __ ] either it
happens at the comedy club what's not
gonna you know I'm saying like it was a
very weird world and it started feeling
unnatural and and I never saw it [ __ ]
coming so November of whatever 99 I
embarked on a world [ __ ] tour it
takes me from coast to coast
close the [ __ ] coast I mean it was
deep and at the end of the tour I come
home it's mm it's April or mm I'm like
okay what am I gonna do so I got a couch
at my buddy's house I give him two
hundred a month to sleep on his [ __ ]
couch and I'm basically doing spots I'm
not taking care of myself I'm eating all
hours I'm drinking I'm doing drugs I'm
living this [ __ ] nomad life and you
know I'm at the Comedy Store seven
nights a week when I'm not on the road
we're Rogen or by myself at that time I
was in a row by myself and lining little
rooms shitty rooms headlining one night
is whatever I could do for six months I
stayed out and this is pretty longest
y'all right five yards before longer
shirt okay so I come back to LA and I
gotta be honest with you guys guys I'm
not thinking about dick
I'm thinking about don't count me
my car had already been towed my
apartment had been told I had already
been through the hell of it I was living
in LA I had no car I was staying at my
friend's couch I lived off the Comedy
Store one night is Philippe Willie
Barcena all four guys like that fly
Jorge Perez you know they all had little
rooms and I did comedy and then I did
the comedy store that was my only income
that was it
so pretty much I lived those April I was
kind of sad I think May of 2000 I had
already come to terms of what was going
on with my daughter and I'm like what is
my next step you know like what is my
next step like I had already shot a
pilot I had booked a commercial and I
made it much much of money I was a
regular at the store nobody liked me
I wasn't going to Montreal I wasn't like
the new sensation I had already come to
terms a lot of little things and I'd
also come to terms with I was pretty
much homeless I lived in that building
whoever had a spare bed that's where I
stayed whoever was out of town if
Ralphie was out of town for a week I had
a place to crash for a week when Gentry
went out of town for a month I had a
place to crash for a month if not
Celine's couch was always available if
not Gavin's couch is always available
this was a [ __ ] wild ride and one
night I go to the [ __ ] comedy store
to do what I usually [ __ ] do and I go
to the bar I get my soda I get my water
and I walk into the [ __ ] hallway at
the economy saw I'm about to go up the
originals room stairs and I saw a girl I
had seen them
or out of the corner of my eye but rule
number one at the store was not to mess
around with the waitresses that Mitch
you will get Maddie I had such a good
thing going with Mitzi that I didn't
want to ruin it so rule number one when
you're a young Tomic if you want to come
back to that club don't sleep with the
waitresses they just don't like it don't
get me wrong you know I snorted coke
with waitresses and did heroin and did
pills and the whole fun content but I
never went back to that club you follow
me so if you want problems in your
career if you don't want no problems in
your career you tip the waitresses
you're very nice so I mean don't get me
wrong love is love
I'm not here to stop love but don't mess
with waitresses but when I walked up the
stairs I had seen this girl before she
was a waitress I had seen this girl
before but for some reason at this time
we locked eyes and I know this doesn't
[ __ ] eyes were you know how dark it
is in the store how [ __ ] eyes are so
beautiful and so blue that I got locked
into them and I did we use most people
do you smile I smiled and said how are
you she was a waitress and I took the
[ __ ] chair and sat down and watched
the show and I did some joke so whatever
the [ __ ] and then later on when it was
time to party I went out then I saw and
I approached her and I asked how long
she had worked there for and she said
about three is I go that's funny you
know because I did see a one night at
coaching horses I was with a bunch of
guys up there and they were sitting in
at that time the only waitress I really
spoke to was Eleanor this girl Olympia
there was a couple waitresses at the
time Eleanor's good friend that I was
tight with but there was a lot of ways I
didn't talk to her did they change too
much or just you were there to do a spa
and get out since didn't you know I
don't know was the first person I met
from Philadelphia right away identify
without knowing this she introduced me
to the waitresses a little
a little and then how is on the road I
wasn't sticking around I was on the road
and what I do come in I would definitely
be there on Sundays but I would leave on
Tuesday Wow
so even if I wasn't here for the week I
would see Mitzi on Sunday so it would
stay fresh in her mind forget about the
week it's what she saw on Sunday so I
would make sure to be back on Sunday to
be with her so that was my plan I went
back I got a drink I think we started
talking about something you know she
told me she was from Tennessee buh buh
buh bah and I think I went home the
first night didn't say anything then I
went up to the store the second night
and then she was again and you know me
dog I'm a sucker for a white chick
they come in all colors and sizes I'm a
sucker for a white chick and I love blue
eyes and I looked at her and we started
talking and she was very sweet and I
just asked her she won't I get [ __ ]
coffee and she said yes
and the next day I took her for coffee
and then she like leading up to this you
had said that you were lonely but like
had it we stood I was lonely but I knew
I didn't want to drag nobody through the
[ __ ] mud when I moved here I moved
here with a girl and I dragged him
through the mud and what does that mean
dragging it through the mud
my life was comedy that's very tough on
a woman that's very tough on a woman
when you meet a girl and you fall in
love with her like I've said a thousand
times at first for a woman it's a
novelty that you're a comedian it's a
novelty but then it becomes a reality
when you knock them up or when you say I
do now it's a different thing they got
you here from a different perspective
now and they start saying to you why do
you have to leave for three weeks why do
you have to leave for two weeks you know
uh yeah and then you have a kid with
them god forbid and then now you're
going on the road and like I said before
you call them saying I'm all right Joey
Diaz house is smoking weed and you can
hear the two kids crying in the
background what so could you understand
me for a woman's perspective it's very
hard so I knew that already
I had already dated a girl in Denver
that [ __ ] didn't like comedy I've
been through this already so when I
moved to the major leagues I this is the
major leagues if I had a hard time
dating with the minor leagues
could you imagine a major leagues it's
like going to prison you want to go to
prison and keep a girl on the outside
you're gonna lose your mind you're gonna
lose your mind you don't want to shoot
yourself in the [ __ ] mouth because
every time you call our house and she
don't answer the phone you're gonna jump
out of your [ __ ] skin your mind takes
you somewhere you're not doing drugs
you're not seeing other women you're not
doing anything so you're sitting in a
cell by yourself watching a
black-and-white TV that's why when you
watch the movie Carlitos away and she
says what happened to you inside and he
goes I didn't want to go through that
when I got locked up I had a girlfriend
and I gotta tell you something I'm not
the overly jealous type
we all have natural jealousy if you have
a girlfriend the guy talks - I'm a
good-looking guy we all have our
insecurities but I saw guys don't kill
themselves in jail over woman I got
stories about guys putting a head
through glasses and [ __ ] Wow I guess my
question like you weren't at a place we
liked actively looking for a girl and
you know why would you want to put
somebody through this [ __ ] Wow this is
my ninth year and I'm working [ __ ] 48
weeks a year I'm in my ninth year and
I'm working 42 48 we see it I'm doing
[ __ ] 30 to 40 spots a month I got no
time for girls I had a girlfriend she
would tell me how far family was coming
it down that's great what the [ __ ] you
want me to do
what we planned the dinner not going on
dinner with your family this I'm doing
the [ __ ] open mic at 8:30 and then I
got this other place at 10:00 I pick up
50 bucks like a purse toward 12:45 what
dinner are you talking about I didn't
know anything I didn't know anything
about that [ __ ] while everybody else is
playing around and going on dates and
doing [ __ ] I wasn't doing that I was
hustling with Felipe I was in the cargo
land me Felipe with Marilyn Marilyn
would pick me up and I was going down
and [ __ ] do a $35 spot and I had a
kick intend to [ __ ] him gasps you know
but that was part of the [ __ ] life I
chose why would I want to but I had a
[ __ ] bag I didn't have furniture we
think I had like a bathroom kit when I
was on the [ __ ] Road I had a bag with
fourth pair of jeans a pair a nice pair
of pants a nice shirt a jacket a suit
jacket I had a couple sweaters and then
a few t-shirts no underwear and socks
that were [ __ ] yellow from foot
fungus and God knows what else that's
all I had gel toothpaste toothbrush
deodorant a [ __ ] razor and some
talcum powder that's it that's in your
travel bag that was my whole [ __ ]
life that was it that's exactly what I
had when I left bulb that's what I
[ __ ] took me the essentials nothing
else came with me when I met Terry
that's what I had so I met her the third
day it was cool and then one night she
brought her girlfriend over to meet me
over at the [ __ ] Ralphie's apartment
Ralphie he's out of town I'm like coming
to my apartment yeah you know I'm saying
I'm making believe like this is my
apartment this is Ralphie's [ __ ] place
I had to tell him I have Terry later on
that's not my place you know so she came
over with a girl we talked the girl
checked me out the girl happened to be
from Long Island we had a few things in
common so not Terry had the green light
kinda sorta so the next day I was broke
and I was [ __ ] hungry
I had like maybe [ __ ] for buck
and I go you know what I'm gonna go take
her out to lunch but she's gonna pay
like I don't know how we're gonna do
this this isn't gonna work
and I [ __ ] walked a mile through a
house rang the doorbell
this is nice to get up at 8:00 and I
would [ __ ] kill time I would go to
like a coffee shop cuz I lived on a
couch when you live on some of these
counters I mean you sleep till twelve
even if you got in there for you got to
get up at eight fold the sheet put it in
the closet take a shower and you got to
go somewhere I would go to a different
apartment and write you know Celine's at
work let me go to her apartment and
right now I would go over there make a
pot of coffee write a little bit take a
shower and then one day like twelve I
was just hungry I thought about her I
really have a crush on her
so I walked from my house at the time to
Haas I didn't have a car nothing I rang
the doorbell she came down and buzzed
being I told the I was hungry and I
wanted to get some food but I only had
like five bucks and she goes [ __ ] it
let's chip in and we'll get lunch and
she made me red beans rice and checked
on her some [ __ ] and I fell in love I
was like this is it this is the girl and
then the next day I asked her to come to
the fourth of July with me in Lake
Havasu I was going to take another comic
with me I was gonna go over to comic but
the comic wanted to take his girlfriend
down when I'm sorry I would have been
the third wheel in the backseat so I
said [ __ ] it let me ask the comedy store
was closed she didn't have to work so I
said what are you gonna do for the
fourth of July she was none I know you
want to go to Lake Havasu no pressure
we could come back that night we don't
for sleep - she goes you know what I'm
not doing dick doesn't sound like a bad
idea went to Lake Havasu on a date that
was 20 years ago tomorrow today
tonight my first experience with but in
a little that I do there's something you
know it's gonna work when
like there's no like like the thing I
hate about dating is like when you feel
like you're pulling teeth in a
conversation and it sounds like we'll
just eat everything was just just kind
of clicked it just it just all came
together in about 10 day period it all
came together
and then she understood my situation she
understood I lived on a couch she
understood this is what I wanted to do I
told her that you know at that time we
were still very early on you know but I
was attracted to I liked and she liked
me so I would go to the calmest or do my
thing way thought to get off and then
she would come over to Ralphie's we were
all like a family we'd all go over to
Ralphie's and eat and smoke and drink
and [ __ ] it you know whatever she didn't
know I was doing blow she pull out what
she's drinking did your bluff slow down
at home we first met around her but then
after a while she would drink so I knew
she wasn't catching it like if you were
sober
I wouldn't snore the ride but once you
started drinking and you got [ __ ] up I
knew you couldn't tell if I was still on
coke because she would see me drinking
if if it was a different life would this
be like someone where you get married in
six weeks
like I no no no no I was not gonna do
more with that mistake I'm not that
[ __ ] stupid you really have to
consider your life when I got the voice
I saw all my shortcomings and I wasn't
gonna put him on another woman unless I
worked on those shortcomings and guess
what after I became a comedian I had
more [ __ ] shortcuts now I had left
off a woman I had nothing to offer a
woman what I have to offer a woman I
didn't have a car I didn't have an
apartment I didn't have a security I
wasn't stable
I had nothing wrong with me the only
thing I had gone for when I met my wife
was that as a member
the Screen Actors Guild I was already a
two-year three-year member of the Screen
Actors Guild besides that I have no
other accolade at that not I had shot a
pilot with CBS and I was doing spots at
the store she had no reason to believe
me I was just running one of the regular
comics that came through the store have
you asked her where was the banner stick
around no I know what made me stick
around when there was a question she
asked me like the first three weeks she
said that she could tell I was raised
without a mother and it really bothered
me because I had met 2,000 people on my
journey and it took a white chick from
Tennessee to tell me that
and that really flipped how I looked at
things and I could also feel that I gave
that energy off so it was a really slow
process like I kept it really slow at
the beginning and it's so weird because
this episode was really gonna be about
love and how when you're looking for
love you make mistakes and when you're
not looking for love you find the
perfect part you know I read everybody
wants to fall in love you know as a
matter of fact I have two friends that
told me within the last week they get
married to girls I'm not gonna give up
let the cat out of the Hat but when you
[ __ ] find that your [ __ ]
workers are gonna flip you know and you
think about it what would I thought
about both of these girls you want me to
tell you what happened over this
pandemic they saw what it was like to be
alone
[Music]
I told you that people gonna really
change these two girls who live to be
single and both of them there's such a
huge age gap and these women one I could
see it that she came to the conclusion
that there's a lot more to comedy I'm
not getting any younger and it's time to
somebody really loves me and they want
to marry me I got to think about it
and one was a young girl that I know
that called me and said I got proposed
to what are you thinking I'm like you
know you just had a picture of you on a
[ __ ] bikini up on YouTube and now
you're getting married how did this
happen I think you're not gonna believe
it
we were friends we both were
relationships we broke up with that
other significant other and we stayed
friends and it just happened and I could
see why both of them are making that
move because this left women with no
security a thousand women realized how
much it feels to be secure now so now
they're looking at men a different way
like I don't ever want to feel this
alone again and there's a lot of guys
that are probably feeling this way right
now absolutely yeah
there's a lot of guys that going you
know [ __ ] I wish I had a girl to talk to
three times a week somebody to come over
maybe a girl needs help with rent no no
I'm not making a lewd statement I'm
saying maybe you know it's somebody who
you're relating to it
you're both broke so you're both putting
your [ __ ] together and eventually you
fall in love it could be a neighbor it
could be the way they up in for a you
know things happen during this pandemic
well I think it's I love the one that I
just I don't want that today that's how
I feel but I don't want to rush into
anything where I'm just so desperate to
to not feel lonely that I'm just going
out with anybody no no no as a pulse and
you've already done that so right now
you're looking but it's so weird how
when all this [ __ ] went down
ten days ago I was talking to my wife
and I went got play Bruce book and
likely you know fine then this book yes
he had a relationship with a stripper
that was crazy and but we're in this
book does he talk about love
there was no love in my life I didn't
want any love of my life because I
thought love would slow me down
I thought me falling in love would slow
my love down for comedy and snow snow
snow my momentum that that's what I
honestly thought on this Lee [ __ ]
thought but he never did do you look
could it be like you live a full life
with it like that maybe maybe you do
slow down a little bit but you have a
better perspective on stager no there
was no perspective there was nothing
again it was really weird because when I
started dating her since it was the
comedy store we kept along that we said
we're gonna be keep this professional so
we both don't lose our jobs
so at The Comedy Store we're gonna be
cool as [ __ ] and then we started dating
like in July and one time in September I
just went over there stayed for like
four days and I was living with her and
then that Sunday after the comi store
her and I went to rock-and-roll Rous on
Sunset and who was in that Elinor Wow
and Elinor seen that she was what the
[ __ ] so we go I don't know we've been
dating but don't say nothing she goes oh
my god this is the unlikeliest couple
like I really was saying and then once
we let the back cat out of the bag a lot
of people raised their [ __ ] hand
especially to her about me saying what
did I wasn't good for her that we were
completely different but I was an animal
on wheels you know the whole [ __ ]
deal but she's like what do you don't
think I you know at that time I was
getting into fist fights at the Konami
store I threw a microphone and a guy you
know so now I was like [ __ ] up
and she's seen this behavior but she
didn't turn her back on me she
understood where I was coming from and
whatever so when she witnessed that
behavior when people told the how
[ __ ] nuts I was it pissed me off and
Hawaii by my side yeah it pissed me off
and made me work harder to prove to her
I wasn't that person people were saying
was mostly guys or girls talking [ __ ]
both really okay both we laugh about it
today I don't get that impulse because
that happens I think that happens a lot
people like to tear stuff down one of
the best friends I had at the time
pulled her aside one night and told her
to be careful with me that I was not
said I might [ __ ] just leave you know
just craziness and she told me maybe
three months later and we both laughed
about it and when we got heavy I hold
the Block on that [ __ ] I never
talk to him again because one you were
cheering against me since day one
why I can't be your friend why we we
broke bread together a thousand times
whatever warning he was telling her I
don't know what the warning was because
I'd been a felon I didn't know what the
warning was so so well yeah at what
point in this sounds like he took it
seriously but like at what point did you
see yours like these she's like really
consider yourself in a relationship like
we were trying to avoid it or I saw
myself in a relationship at the 90-day
mark but I didn't want like I said I
don't like taking people down dark
streets so I didn't I kept her at arm's
distance even though we lived together
it was very weird we work together so
she was with me
if I was there she was there if she
wasn't working she was with me do you
find the same here so
she was working I was doing a spot and
if she wasn't working she'd still drive
me down to the sea of friends at that
time the store was everything to us so
we were down there pretty much seven
nights a week
very seldom from the time I met her in
June to maybe for about 18 months we you
know we were like [ __ ] two peas in a
pod
the only time I wouldn't be with her was
when I would go on the road with Rogan
but you said you were whole you were
keeping her arm's length like
emotionally well part I loved her I
can't [ __ ] but I wasn't ready to get
married
I was really far away from getting
married I still had to prove myself to
me I wasn't gonna do to her how I failed
the first time there was no two ways
there was no two ways about it
that I couldn't handle it I couldn't
handle being married the first time and
I was a civilian Here I am [ __ ] mad
become a comedian I can't handle it so
for a while there I was I was dating her
waiting they get dumped so I was waiting
to get dumped from The Comedy Store I'm
waiting to get dumped by her because I
really wasn't doing nothing productive I
was doing spots I wasn't making any
money I was breaking even some months I
would make half the rent
some months I would give it to her in
two installments I wasn't doing anything
sensational out of this world I was
paying a couple things off at the same
time and then I started then she talked
me into going to the IRS I think it was
at the two-year mark where I realized
that I was with a girl who had my back
this was not a one-night stand this was
not something that was she was my
girlfriend to be cool there was
to be cool about by being my girlfriend
see if I was anything there was nothing
to be cool about she sincerely cared
about me and I sincerely care about her
I can't about us so much that I was
embarrassed about the drugs and that
lifestyle that's the only real thing I
hid from her I wasn't really and you
gotta remember one thing the last five
years of my addiction I didn't really
get high with people somebody sent me an
email yeah that my dad said he gonna
hire you in 1988 in New York City bad
news I didn't live in 88 in New York
City I was in prison stupid you know
tell your father stop smoking weed you
[ __ ] Momo so no I I just didn't wanna
I didn't want to take somebody down a
hole like I did the first time so I kind
of kept our arm's distance till about
yeah about the second year and then I
really I went to sign up at a rehab one
time just to give it a try if I could
make it I was trying to go on there
anonymously without somebody saying hey
I saw you at the split second [ __ ]
meeting somebody [ __ ] bugged me so I
couldn't go back there I even signed up
under a fake name the whole [ __ ] deal
Hill this is before like they was ask
you fish [ __ ] this is like voluntary
form you have an ID no I don't have a
with me bring it next time yeah I'll
bring it next time I ain't bringing the
next time so I took about two years and
then three years and I started caring
more more but at the same time I had to
let her know that calmly was number one
at that point and that's very hard in
the relationship how'd she take it like
a trooper and it wasn't by my words it
was by my actions she saw me all those
nights come home
with you know she saw me order and head
shots at 9:00 in the morning she saw me
stuffing envelopes you know she saw me
leave at 10 o'clock to go to casting
directors to drop off things it just
wasn't the guy that got up and stayed on
the couch I got up in the morning i
vacuumed I did some laundry I [ __ ]
got on the phone she taught me how to
use the computer
oh I mean I had no idea how to use the
[ __ ] computer and it was just a
process 2009 were together nine years
over for a Santeria reading the guy
talked some about me getting married I
called her up at although we'll get
married she said yes I called a father
on the phone he said yes that was the
end of it I married him about a month
ago I realized that July 1st is going to
be our 20th anniversary and I sat down
liver and I said think about what
happened the last time he is like we
went from a couple that was living a
studio apartment in noisy Hollywood how
Hollywood with ten cats to move into the
valley living a couple life which was
really good we had date night we had all
this [ __ ] you know we would go to eat on
Friday nights like nice old the couples
we thought we're never gonna have kids
and [ __ ] life throws you a [ __ ]
fastball and you hit it out of the park
and now we have a kid that's what
happened the last 10 years not to
mention commonly see these [ __ ] the
road you know
not to mention all these [ __ ] things
- bit overwhelming it's so weird when
you're 20 you really have nothing to
look back on you think life this life
when you get to be 30 you think about
your 20s when you get to be 40 you think
about your 20s and 30s now and you learn
more and more by yourself you know and
it's so weird out of the other damn like
you know there's so many people
who listen to the church that yeah
there's a lot of guys in the [ __ ]
Larry you know J bish you know Bob you
know a link lies a lot of guys are Mary
you know Bobby Sharon and they got
girlfriends but there's a lot of guys
there's a lot of women who listen for
the church still the [ __ ] single you
know and it's so weird how you cannot
give up on love and it's not gonna be at
a bar it's not gonna be I had a [ __ ]
love spiritual retreat it's gonna be
crossing the street it's gonna be maybe
he rear-ended you in a mall and you
start talking and you exchanged numbers
and the guy calls you and ask you for
dinner or vice versa why does he have to
call you you like this ass [ __ ] call
him dirty [ __ ] well you know I mean
this is what this is about how do you
ever think about that about how when you
first matter
you get out of prison you've been
divorced not talking to the kid you're
broke you very easily could have told
yourself actions want to go out with me
[ __ ] [ __ ] asking her for coffee I'll
just go do a bomb placed and there's one
thing since we're judging here and we
made assumptions off off videos here
there's girls that there's girls that
you ask to go to the bathroom and do a
bump and there's girls that you ask out
for coffee what that behavior is when
you ask them is up to them all right
when you even asking Terry out as
opposed to you just being like not even
talking or like having like being open
to the even asking someone else I don't
know I didn't know if I was lonely I
didn't know if I wanted to sleep for
there I really didn't know but I knew
that I like to rise I knew I liked her
accent
I knew I liked a lot of things about her
when I first met her her walked a
toughness she was kind of tough on me
when I first met her I liked all that
stuff so I loved that's a question I got
it it's weird like you know when you go
on the road and you go to [ __ ] a
snake City North Dakota and you get
offstage and you [ __ ] talk to a girl
and then you know maybe she goes to your
hotel room maybe she does it you know
what possesses you what confidence do
you have to ask that girl I mean she'll
tell you you know you know this last
couple of weeks since these things came
out that people were pissed off and
whatnot it's so weird how you think
about the comic life
and I'm gonna tell you a story that
takes me back to 1992 okay this is how
[ __ ] crazy comedy is now let's get
something straight
I've always considered myself a thief a
good burglar I was a good basketball
player when I was a kid there was a
couple things I was good at you know
what I wasn't good at [ __ ] you know
what else I wasn't good at either if I
was sober I would never ask a woman a
question if it wasn't for alcohol and
drugs I wouldn't talk to women they gave
me that confidence okay so let's get
something straight right out of the way
if I'm sober my chances are talking to
you unless you talk to me I'm very
slimming
yeah very slim especially when I was a
young man they were very very slim okay
when I got into town I got into comedy
for various reasons but I never know so
I get on stage July 18 1991 October we
split up I meet a girl she goes to New
York we're talking
what we're not exclusive I'm living with
a roommate at the time he's got a couple
jobs but one of his main jobs is selling
powder so one night I must have stayed
in I passed out early at that time I was
doing stand-up on Tuesdays and maybe
like Thursday nights but I was eating a
ton of aliens and I was drinking I was
eating a ton of Valium because I was
selling Valiant
and I was drinking so it's sleep a lot I
would fall asleep whenever I got high I
told that story on rogue and that valium
sits in your fat white only half of it
gets activated so one night guys I
[ __ ] pass out like on the couch
watching TV it's a mutual liberal it's
three roommates at the time it was just
me in it now I know what this guy does
for a living part-time he drives a cab
he's a vocational school teacher he
helps young kids get scholarships and
he's a major league coke dealer that's
what helped them finance everything
everything else was [ __ ] to cover
his income sparking another one for you
[ __ ] I want to get this party
started
it's fourth of July weekend you
[ __ ] the [ __ ] you doing get that
thing going who gives a [ __ ] your home
you got your [ __ ] business shirt on
you got some [ __ ] New England paid
for your shorts on who gives the [ __ ]
you probably just finished whacking off
roll up a number smoke what uncle Joey
this as good as it gets fourth of July
weekend no beach they're locking
everybody up today I'm saying by the
time this podcast comes out this
afternoon California will be in a total
[ __ ] lockdown okay so I know so the
government Newsom is gonna make an
announcement this morning by the time
this podcast comes out come on Lou
someone's gonna say we're done la Bamba
is over gyms are closing [ __ ] I hope
my daughters can't doesn't close
tomorrow
we're supposed to go to the beach today
so why wet the beach loosens gonna be
giving this [ __ ] story time for
joining and now for a word from our
sponsor a [ __ ] number so I'm living
with this guy he comes home at like 3:00
in the morning and goes Joey Joey you
fell asleep on the couch I don't know
[ __ ]
Jeannie let me go up to my room
he goes no you can't go up to my room
because you can't call the stairs you
got do me a favor I went to this [ __ ]
party and some guy came up to me I'm
over I had a couple packages I got rid
of a couple packages but this guy aspect
for a package that's a little weird I go
home I said how big of a package he goes
on a second that's not weird I know how
much coke they got buy from you already
ain't got a boy he bought like four
grams already they're going you come
home I mean you're already half dead
they would have followed you over there
the cops oh yeah say goes no I don't
think he's a cop but I'm not sure I said
[ __ ] it at that time the cops are
looking for me at the accuracy
I had the Acura and I hadn't paid the
[ __ ] the cops were looking for me the
tow truck dude
oh no the tow truck dude was looking for
me side the Acura hidden in the garage
and I borrowed like this [ __ ] you
know sloppy jalopy that you had a
[ __ ] you know it didn't run right in
the [ __ ] and I parked it around the
corner so the people in the tow truck
we're looking for me I'd be driving
around town and the [ __ ] up car he's
gonna saying so I had a a little backup
car you couldn't take out a bulb he's
gonna blow up and he day was gonna blow
up like a friend of mine just said just
hold on to it but it blows up a bad that
[ __ ]
I'll say it stole him like to [ __ ]
wipe the handlebar whatever side parked
it around the corner from now so I gonna
leave you do this I go way up the coke
give me the address
[ __ ] enjoy the set I'll go over there
and since it's me alone I'll make
believe I'm looking for an address for a
party so if I get pulled over by a cop
that looks suspicious I can just say I
got invited to a party in here not with
me and I'll call you from the party he
goes there's a girl there they we
mutually know when you get to the party
tell her and call me and I'll be here
waiting for you call there's no cell
phones back that or nothing so I let's
say the the joint is here I Drive around
like four blocks surrounding that
looking for undercover cops oh [ __ ]
okay when I didn't see any unmarked cars
or anything I wanted for this [ __ ]
party I see the girl I gonna call Manny
she calls Manny Manny she told what the
coke man he throws me a taste for being
his back to his wingman and I mingle I'm
mingling with the girl I'm talking to
people it's 4:00 in the morning it's a
Friday night we're talking about this
we're talking about that the chick says
listen do me a favor if you want to go
to the backyard and talk go talk that
the party's getting bigger I have a
basement I got the four yard but let's
get out of living room so some of these
says there's a pool table and there's a
ping-pong table downstairs so I go
downstairs
guys I'm doing comi maybe 14 months
I am [ __ ] horrible I am horrible at
comedy I'm going on stage every Tuesday
I'm just embarrassing myself every
Tuesday I'm going up there with Madonna
tits and I'm crawling up there with a
suit well the dollar hits me you know
when she did Vogue oh she had those two
cones I went up there one week to Vogue
with cones I mean I experiment that
whatever they had told you before so I
was just a horrible comic and we think
I'm bad now you should assume it I'm
doing currently about fourteen months
I'm downstairs I'm shooting pool and
there's nobody shooting pool with me you
know like when you're just shooting pool
like I'm shooting there's probably six
people downstairs
I hope awesome this girl comes up to me
beautiful I was 30 years old maybe she
was 34 35 36 37
well Hall doesn't mention kids and we
start talking one thing leads to another
she stunk I'll come don't coke
we shoot pool I think I beat her and
pool and she goes you know what I
guarantee you can't beat me a [ __ ]
ping pong I got been shot beach in ping
pong 10 bucks 10 bucks one thing led to
another we played a couple of times and
it got down to show me a tits or
something or a [ __ ] I don't know what
it came out we played ping pong father
wake her father fool around with me we
have the [ __ ] I won it's not gonna
pimple I wasn't good at ping pong I
think she drew a game it's like a
breeder and we started messing around
she got up but that's what she said to
me when she came downstairs she goes
when you walked in I couldn't figure out
who you were that's the point of this
whole story because I couldn't figure
out who you were I go who the [ __ ] am i
and she goes you're the host at the
broker on Tuesday nights ago what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
and she goes [ __ ] my husband's into
comedy we've gone down and see different
comedians and when you came and I saw
you oh my god you're a celebrity I'm
like I'm no [ __ ] are you crazy I'm doing
comedy 14 months and people what have
you been like I've been in [ __ ] like she
told me in front of a bunch of people
and I'm like done no I got a day job
I've been in [ __ ] like what movies have
you been nothing it's 1990 [ __ ] - I
don't even dream about movies I'm just
trying to get on a stage a few times a
week what I always think about that like
that was the begin
and that's how crazy it was for a game
of [ __ ] ping pong so for some people
listening to this yeah it was 30 and
life was a lot different and your state
of mind was a lot different but by the
time I was 37 I was like this lifestyle
can't continue because it's not who I am
but I don't want a girlfriend either I
gotta find the happy medium well God
didn't show up with a [ __ ] lab
immediately
God ladle um didn't like Bon Jovi said I
got it right the first time
and like I said I kept my head diction
from in the first couple years I talked
to him but I didn't talk to about calmly
we were tight we went out to dinner we
adopted cats I went home to Tennessee
with her but we didn't really it was
like a very light relationship it was
until 2004 when I shot the longest shard
that I realized she was the woman for me
but I still couldn't waste her time with
marriage I got I got my always said time
average I'm a bum who cares if I got a
movie that that's just a stupid [ __ ]
movie I know how it is in this town
these people get one movie and awesome
they're [ __ ] moving to Beverly Hills
then you sit there are they might here
for this anyway if a 90 agent just
blowing smoke up your [ __ ] ass so
just because I had to move he didn't
mean I was gonna propose to her it just
mean it came to me when I got that movie
that this was the woman for me now if I
was gonna go to the next level I needed
her and I and I went back to my youth to
me telling a friend of mine the younger
I wanted to do we were kids
her name was I'm not gonna tell you what
the name was I mean we were both the
same age we were about 19 and she dated
a friend of mine and when they broke up
this girl one of the revenge you know
none of the [ __ ] many guys she wanted
it I never slept with her but she came
up to me to approach the sky one time
she goes I know you taught
talk to him for me fixed me up on him
see if he'll take me on a date I like
guys with money and one day [ __ ]
around I said to a man such and such
says she wants you to take him on a date
I go I hear stories of body this bro why
would I go on a date with her rule what
I got he goes the woman I'm with was
with me when I had nothing before these
gas stations and the [ __ ] fruit
stands and everything me and her I want
a one-bedroom apartment even [ __ ]
tuna and sardines how would I ruin it
for [ __ ] some 19 year old 20 year old
[ __ ] bimbo that statement ring
[ __ ] coaches with me yeah and it
still ranks cultures with me today as
far as uh so the sad thing about this is
the good thing about this is listen I
stuck with something for twenty years
and I worked really hard at it
we got tighter over the [ __ ]
coronavirus I told you guys that there
was gonna be a silver lining
listen I'm like you guys colvett meant
pay cut it meant paid that there was
nothing you could do there was nothing
and I'm all about it
you know I'm not gonna collect
unemployment we'll have a but it's a pay
cut you know this one is whether you're
in the food industry can you imagine
being hoping for a week and now they
closed you up look if the store was open
for a night yeah
the comedy store but now they're opening
back up to serve food okay so we go down
there maybe one night next week get a
couple chicken fingers and some prize
and say hello and you know maybe get
some own to go down there and Dean down
rain you know no it's a terrible thing
exactly so I get what the [ __ ] is
happening so uh my point of the story is
you know I stuck it out it wasn't it was
20
[ __ ] hell years I changed for her I
stop snorting cold fur well you know
what I became man for I had to become a
man to win her over
fully for her to gain confidence in me
and the morale the story is that listen
guys you never - all love is around the
corner man love is always around the
corner you cannot control it I don't
know if there's a cupid I don't know if
there's a Santa Claus but and I'm gonna
tell you something else that God has put
a few good women in my life he has and
even when I lived in Boulder all those
months after I got divorced I met some
solid girls that would have ran with me
I just that wasn't that really wasn't
for me at that time so you know a man
you kiss a lot of frogs before you get a
prince with me I kissed a lot of frogs I
wasn't looking for a prince and one day
a prince just showed up princess
whatever the [ __ ] you want to call a
prince princess I don't give a [ __ ] okay
you guys know what I'm talking about
what uh but that's some more of a story
man if you're lonely right now my heart
goes out to you but hey there's an ass
for every [ __ ] seat and eventually
true love will come your way if it's
meant like I said the two women that
approached me recently and told me they
were gonna get married blew my [ __ ]
socks off because they're both two women
that enjoy being single but this
coronavirus this time being alone made
you realize this isn't how you wanna
[ __ ] die you don't want to die by
yourself you want to die with somebody
next to you holding your hand you know
so I'm very fortunate 20 years today
the sad part about this is I can't even
take it to a dinner I can't even take it
to a dinner you know chicken fingers of
the store I was gonna wanna have
something and then she told me she
didn't want it and we were just gonna go
to [ __ ] the hotel maybe for two
nights of lord
our plans have been ruined but we're
gonna have a good time today we're gonna
go to the beach and then tonight cook
some on the grill and hopefully this
weekend and have a happy safe what did
July if they shut us down they shut us
down what do you want me to do with them
a boycott it you want me to scream up
and down because [ __ ] they think I
gotta wear a mask is that what you want
me to do is go to a [ __ ] supermarket
and [ __ ] yell and scream cuz they're
gonna make me wear a mask guess what
guys I didn't like wearing the sleep
apnea mask but I could have [ __ ] died
if I didn't wear it so I learned to like
it and now you know what if we're in it
[ __ ] saves other people's lives and
it cuts down this horrible [ __ ] thing
we're going through and hopefully we get
back to [ __ ] normal again I suggest
you do us all a favor it's it's you know
it's it's [ __ ] American of you I went
to the party I get to the [ __ ] park
again no racist comments on the [ __ ]
show ok I got you you choose yourself
when you you fill in the [ __ ] bike I
take my dog to do the [ __ ] podcast
this afternoon from there I go honey you
got a wild I handed you and me take me
to the park I go to the park you're not
gonna believe this guys I got my
daughter in a [ __ ] tree with red ants
oh okay yeah she thought I don't give a
[ __ ]
let me get bit by an ant but you know
just one how to understand she wants to
climb trees and there's a it she only
got a bit one time no gonna happen you
have to go a certain level to get the
ants so I'm sitting there with my
daughter now am I the best American no I
don't vote I got felonies you know I'm a
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] I pay taxes I
don't want to go to jail so but I'm not
the best American in the world now the
park is wrapped around there's yellow
police tape around it does yellow police
tape on the [ __ ] swings
that's what uncle Joey sees - I know how
do you be more me to react
as an American 40 years ago and every
right to get a stick and hit these
people in the head with sticks and their
families and the capital applauded me so
this yellow tape around this [ __ ]
thing you could tell they don't want
your honest now again I don't know if
I'm being racist if I am my early
apologies don't report me to Apple Joe
we said racist things I'm just telling
you what I observed there's yellow
[ __ ] police tape around the [ __ ]
children's [ __ ] thing they don't want
you on there the only reason why I'm
there is I know a tree that my daughter
likes I ride my bike there and there's a
tree that she could stand in the middle
and walked up by three steps and she
jumps long let me tell you my daughter
gonna do that in an hour
82 times all you people are
I've been step jump and I've lost 11
pounds come up against my daughter
you'll [ __ ] die of a heart attack she
could jump on that tree and jump off 82
times I've seen it I'm Sheena do that
for like eight minutes straight just
Chuck and pick up my legs all the way to
a chest so you guys don't know nothin
about none you know people had more
cardio than our the ludus that's it
I met this [ __ ] Park I'm minding my
own business sober as a [ __ ] judge
didn't even smoke grief I think this is
my last Johnny I ain't got no weed left
so I got I got a weed store real quick a
little while herb entries went or I
maybe I throw you over and I'll make a
back switch you go to a different week
so I get you [ __ ] Mama's waiting over
there so I go to the park I'm minding my
business what do you think I see a
Chinese guy Wow
in the [ __ ] thing the toys were the
rattle whether there's like a bridge
that faithfully rattles like it's the
like a [ __ ] ramp and Titanic like
people gonna fall off it's a Chinese man
with three kids no masks on and you
ready face is the clinker bad foot like
kung fu class dog I almost had a [ __ ]
heart attack no masks on everybody's
looking at him like really like we let
you in you're cool and then you gotta
come to the park no masks on with those
[ __ ] feet
god knows what peanuts was it's like
someone was trying to get you oh my
daughter even came over looked at me
when Jesus Christ was that's how
embarrassing it was and you try to be a
nice person but this is what you see the
thing is roped-off not only does he go
on it no masks the kids no mass
breathing [ __ ] uh Vietnam man
whatever the [ __ ] they shot over Vietnam
Agent Orange all over the [ __ ]
playground on kids with no shoes on how
am I supposed to [ __ ] act you can't
say not 20 30 years ago you go up to
people go excuse me let me talk to you
about something but the mask on or the
[ __ ] shoes I'm gonna shoot your
[ __ ] kid in the foot or something
like that seriously America was
completely different we've changed our
views company you couldn't talk a
different language in public in the 70s
you couldn't do it you couldn't come on
and just beat your [ __ ] language
people go it's America but now we gotta
be sensitive to people's [ __ ] feelings
but anyway who gives two flying [ __ ]
about feelings of what comes out of
people's mouths I'm just happy it's the
fourth of July we're gonna have a good
weekend either way when they lock you up
or you're not listen if you're having a
hard time you didn't pay the rent
[ __ ] it they're gonna evict you anyway
let them get you out lock the door put a
[ __ ] Bureau in front of that let them
barricade yeah you're like one of the
[ __ ] loonies let them [ __ ] shoot
it does that you don't give a [ __ ] you
ain't going nowhere you tie a rope
around the back window and when you're
ready to go you go on your own terms to
them since you ain't going I'm a third
[ __ ] them
this sheriff could not fall he wants I
shot this sure buddy shoot the deputy or
I don't give a [ __ ] no more podcasters
are you loving wonderful like theme of
like barricade here's open your
apartment I don't give a [ __ ] I'm just
trying to tell you people the truth you
know same I don't want you to feel bad
or listen his life happens you lost your
job you're on unemployment and Zahran
meaning this does not mean you're a bad
person
that means your bad per you're a good
person a bad position don't let it get
the whole do you don't let money get the
besties there's no debtors prison this
is what it is your family you have your
friends you know you have your
co-workers you know call them up don't
go crazy you know March and April rough
on me also coming to terms with all this
[ __ ] we've come to terms with it let's
move on you know
2020 is wiped off the plate what do you
want to do you want to crying your
[ __ ] soup you want to blame it on
this you want to blame it on the
political this or the [ __ ] election
listen it is what it is oh it's doctor
pouchy doctor thought you didn't do
nothing who knows what happens this is
what they threw at us now we're gonna
accept it pick up the pieces and move
forward moving forward is big right now
and then you could do I never said you
were a deadbeat you know I'm saying
things happen so don't take nothing
personally enjoy the [ __ ] our day man
and listen I've been in worse
predicaments this ain't [ __ ] they can
take away your apartment they can take
away your car but they can't take away
your dignity who the [ __ ] you are and
what you've worked for so don't get down
it's a 4th of July listen go buy a bag
of weed and I'm [ __ ] V Z and I paying
that either [ __ ] I'm saying who gives
the [ __ ] go get a cash advance and tell
visa yeah yeah I'll keep sending your
minimums up my weight and when you shut
the lights you shut the lights out on
all the tell them all to go [ __ ]
themselves they tricked you they told
all of us that was like I'm not gonna be
in a victim moratorium right and guess
what people are getting evicted
people are getting evicted so they
tricked us so it's you know what don't
feel bad about it [ __ ] happens
well that's what I think everyone should
do unemployment if you see today that
could one of the companies that we gave
tax dollars to is gonna charge something
like like seventy thousand dollars for a
covert 19 pill like something crazy when
when we gave them millions of dollars we
want
you didn't know that that's how the scam
works who gives a [ __ ] about that I'm
talking about individuals get your
unemployment out I have no I think
there's a big stigma against it I if you
if you worked and earned your own
employment I must say ask for free money
but have you worked and paid into it
work for it get your money I told you
since day one I've told you since day
one how to handle this I told you since
day one so I don't want to [ __ ] hear
it but I do sympathise with a lot of
families that are missing meals I
sympathize or a lot of men who are
feeling down right now I sympathize with
a lot of women who are feeling down
right now
listen it's just money it does not
reflect on you depression should nots
again get a notebook write what you're
doing right out of plan how you gonna
get you so fatherless don't be proud
your mother's got a basement move in it
you know your mother-in-law's got a
basement move in it I'd rather you have
something than nothing and have a chance
to start over and that's hitting that
that as far as Tommy dates are concerned
I got nothing go [ __ ] yourself the board
is clean do we living in a [ __ ]
pandemic you know people are shooting
each other I'm gonna sit at home my
family my business is smoke reefer and I
suggest you do the same do not forget
this weekend me and Lee I don't know if
it's gonna be Friday night or Saturday
we're gonna pop up with a little
Instagram live wish you a personal
[ __ ] happy 4th of July
and just to check in with you there's
gonna be a long week I know that's a
half you guys gonna be sitting there
with your finger up your ass you've
already watched everything on [ __ ]
Netflix the French stuff the Chinese
stuff you use VPN to get your [ __ ]
Express you be in it expressvpn to get
you the anime you know you've done it
all you're sick of watching we're gonna
call up on you we're gonna sneak up on
you maybe Friday and Saturday night say
hello and check in with your mother
[ __ ] beside that I want to thank you
guys for listening they're a week I want
to thank on it but you [ __ ]
it's Wednesday [ __ ] July first the
rent is due
and who gives a [ __ ] I'm saying you were
looking for a job when you had that one
they can all suck your dick and call you
shorty see you Monday more than with the
church brand-new [ __ ] Monday ready to
rock the fifth or the sixth of July can
you believe it's going that fast
stay black have a good weekend Lee kick
this [ __ ] Miyagi
[Music]